carrière bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct alors je viens de le dire un
confinement d'une banlieue de tel aviv
où le taux de contamination est le plus
élevé du pays qu'en est il du reste de
l'état alors écoutez c'est assez
intéressant de voir c'est la progression
de ces deux des événements apnée brac
donc c'est dans l'ue de telles vives qui
est essentielle non essentiellement
habité par des vieux des extrémistes
religieux des ultra religieux parce que
le taux de contamination est d'environ
34% alors qu'at&t la ville par exemple
où je réside le taux de contamination
par rapport évidemment en nombre de gens
testé pour l'instant il aux alentours de
5 6% ce qui démontre quand même que
lorsque les consignes sont respectées
on arrive à plus ou moins au niveau
gouvernemental à contrôler la situation
aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble d'israël
nous avons 6300 pitois 6300 personnes
qui ont été excusés moi tout mais
d'autres sont en anglais qui ont été
quelques sont considérés comme atteindre
du corona et nous avons malheureusement
à ce jour plus de 30 morts évidemment
les chiffres sont en augmentation
permanente puisque nous assistons à une
contamination qui est exponentielle je
pense que le pi tu vas être atteint aux
alentours du 15 avril
et je pense qu'à ce moment là on aura
quelques milliers de morts et ça c'est
actuellement épouvantable mais bon c'est
une réalité
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
confinement total de la population vous
confirmez ça dépend ce que vous appelez
le confinement total
il faut savoir qu'en israël règles de
confinement ont été mises en place bien
avant l'europe et que déjà moi je même
scandé sous ferme si je vais à paris aux
alentours du 5 mars et je n'ai pas pu le
faire puisque on ne pouvait plus
retourner en israël sauf d'accepter
d'être confiné dès son retour
donc non mais ma compagne et moi avons
renoncé à ce déplacement en israël
depuis donc le début mars
tout le monde a progressivement été
appelés être confiné de façon plus ou
moins volontaire des hôtels ont été
réquisitionnés pour être transformés en
place du con
une embrouille certains patients et
notamment les gens qui reviennent de
l'étranger et cette scène cette
situation conduit à générer quelque
chose de plus ou moins un contrôle est
pour l'instant dans l'ensemble du pays
je vois par exemple par rapport à la
situation en italie en espagne qui sont
entièrement catastrophique je pense que
en israël nous allons arriver à contenir
plus ou moins quand même l'épidémie
puisque l'école et que les directives
sont quand même assez bien respectée par
une population
kerry yob merci d'avoir été en direct
avec moi je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et réalisateur et auteur de
ted a retrouvé aux éditions mécanique
générale merci